14 hard days of chess ahead how
important is physical fitness the basic
outfit Mithen the body throughly
everything he'd been Fisher noted that
fact 50 years ago it's very important I
mean I'll definitely use this great gym
we have I just run and I like to play
football but yesterday I was swimming in
the swimming pool which is fantastic
here I try to do some weight and I swim
usually I do stuff like hiking or
running it's more so that you have
energy throughout for a much longer
duration I find out much more relevant
than say doing something like like
CrossFit for example which not a fan of
even something like interval training
which I think Rex used to be a big fan
of I believe in doing stuff that like it
goes for much longer periods of time
physical fitness is especially important
to say for myself the last couple of
years have been pretty exhausting in
terms of number of tournaments played I
mean there were times where I played
pretty much three months of chess
straight and some events are more
exhausting than others like the
candidates for example is much more
exhausting than than a normal tournament
where there's money at stake and there's
you know prestige it was more like
mental exhaustion definitely at some
point you'll have blackouts with the
guys who are not that fit you know when
you look at the position and you cannot
force yourself to make a move I mean
your brain is already not functioning I
think it happens to everybody when all
of your sugar is depleted and you're
tired you're just freeze if you switch
cities that enables you to draw a line
very clearly I mean the old tournament
becomes history and you start the new
one it's much easier to refresh so to
speak if you if you move elsewhere even
a change of hotel change of scenery
something you know it's different yeah
yeah something like that
I mean once the golfers have all gone we
can we can go to the country club maybe
I don't know